e você viu mesmo aí mesmo em seu show
especial de comédia está disponível lá
na Netflix tá o nome é adulto é só você
pesquisar adulto vai aparecer um monte
d********* do lado que o meu né se você
não tiver Netflix você pode pedir
emprestado com algum amigo seu agora nós
vamos saber quem é amigo de verdade de
quem aqui em e agora para me ajudar um
pedido meu pedido amigo meu mais uma Me
ajuda aí mas aí Me ajuda aí posta essa
hashtag aqui lá no lá no Twitter pode
ser até agora assim sai de vídeo bem
rapidinho vai no Twitter porta #assista
adulto na Netflix a isso aí sou eu mesmo
tô pedindo meu mesmo que eu tô pedindo
mesmo para você assim como pedir de
amigos impedindo mesmo assim Costa
lavá-la eu voltei a fazer show em no mês
de agosto já tem um Feira de Santana no
dia 24 lá em Feira de Santana loja dia
25 Natal Rio Grande do Norte vou estar
em Natal e em todos os ingressos 31
Parnaíba Piauí de volta à Terrinha Alien
em setembro tem Caxias no Maranhão
Petrolina Pernambuco Picos Piauí de novo
psique de novo não quebre o Palmas
Tocantins dia Quatorze de Setembro
Goiânia nós vamos fazer lá no Goiânia
Arena compre seus ingressos dia 21
Recife
em Pernambuco Haddad Recife 28 Campo
Grande Mato Grosso do Sul 29 Cuiabá Mato
Grosso como seus ingressos em é nós
achei que propaganda se eu for falar
alguma coisinha mais é Netflix mas é ser
bem rápido tipo vou postar lá uma
hashtag lá na seja adulto na Netflix por
favor aqui de amigo na Netflix tá né no
Netflix coisa eu assistir Os Vingadores
né esse filme começa como fosse o final
do filme né que quando temos faz assim
eu sou inevitável todo mundo vira poeta
escutamos tinha eliminado metade das
criaturas vivas da terra qual pessoas
ruins gente não dadas Não tente
aleatória Metade das pessoas da terra
aleatórias começaram a subir na poeira e
saindo então viu aquela p****** teve
avião que tava voando sumir a passagem
no meio da viam que outro surge que aí
avião onde você vai morrer enfim eu
imagino que deveria ser um trauma é mais
tempo todo mundo pelo mundo fazer
desempenhando suas funções do nada
algumas pessoas começam a sumir algumas
e ficar muito doido porque tipo ia ver
uma pessoa subindo outro ia dar muito
certo
e o negócio de mágica aí o cara vai Oi
vou fazer a mulher cortar ele não veio
para tá faltando a mulher no meio que
ela começa eu só ia olhar a população e
falar assim à toa que o pessoal na
plateia e o bicho moleque vem
impressionante viu morrer transformou
uma atualização para o número que é
antiga que achou que era só serrar
mulher no meio como era antigamente de
repente a pessoa para pessoa falar sumiu
cara pegou a gente de surpresa velho ela
impressionou velho Diga aí Josiane
Josiane eu vou subir uma mulher aqui
também aqui ó aqui de volta tava na
igreja o Pastor Pregando porque em nome
de Jesus nós iremos mas na Rua Jerusalém
o que ela começa a falar foi-se embora
peguei então como é que foi o código
Rapaz o homem é um jeito viu terminou o
culto foi direto para o céu uma benção
Gavião Arqueiro é ensinando as coisas
filha dele pois aqui flecha né Lógico
que é isso que
é estranho não deixar a tirar aquela
flecha ele dá uma meu Valtinho quando
volto Cadê a menina só os farelos
subindo aí o o magoni o meu amigo é
doido esse homem sai dois atrás dessa
menina procurando e gritando e chorando
imagina Manda para a pessoa que tu ama
far ela na tua frente assim quando ela
assim igual o corpo Tapioca e ele
correndo atrás dessa menina eu
aproveitando para comer né que a cena
era de dia eu aproveito cena de dia em
filme para ver o que é que eu tô comendo
no cinema porque fica tudo escuro Sabe
aquele óculos e revelar a enfiando a mão
dentro do refrigerante leve a pipoca
entendeu Tipo toda errada aí quando fica
uma cena de dia que ela veio tudo o que
tá bom quem tá pipoca Que dava perante
aqui todo o chocolate que eu botei aqui
tava né Aí fica escondido eu já sei onde
é que tá aí eu tudo bem eu sou assim com
o filme até um rack Zinho a forminha né
porque organização seja de mergulho toda
sendo de mergulho eu paro de respirar
junto para ver se eu ia aguentar também
fazer o mesmo a cor que a pessoa do
filme tá aguentando quarto desafio seu
contato que eu ia morrer mesmo bem
rápida e toda vez que o ator já tá
chegando o que tinha que fazer alguém
e em alguma coisa aí tem que voltar para
buscar aí nessa volta do apoio Mueller
eu ia morrer eu e uma pessoa eu tentando
puxar um pé da pessoa porta para um
universo Tony Stark mago velho pobre em
jogando travinha com a filha do thanos
nebula né azul que aquela família é uma
paleta de maquiagem né o plano é roxa A
Débora é azul agora verde eu tô está
aqui brincando né com ela porque ele
estava perdido no espaço que o que
aconteceu foi que é a nave parou de
funcionar e ficar lá pelo espaço
perdendo vagando isso que eu tô está com
amargura daquele jeito e jogando com a
né colocar logo a gente vai no churrasco
só que a única pessoa que tem no
churrasco para gente se enturmar e
conversar a única pessoa que a gente
conhece é um p******** da escola tá
andando essas festas encontro de família
só velho monte de velho toalha por lá o
p******** só pega com o p******** da
loira aí você que passa churrasco
todinho conversando eu volto para escola
livre para o risco pau no goleiro tem um
bolo gordinho aí tu volta para escola
meio do cara tu não apanha mais eles já
tão desenganado que a a ficar parada
vagando no espaço tá
e ela não come não ri não faz nada então
gasta de energia ele manda o velho tá
acabando a bateria de uma roupa dele e
Adivinha que ele chega para salvar eles
cantam Capitão Marvel aqui eu tô fazendo
a capitão capitão Marvel faz pega os
dois leva para terra não ela leva a nave
dupla da terra e traz com quem tá
fazendo uma sacola de supermercado assim
da senhora tá aqui já tá entregue
aparece Capitão América do lindo demais
meu Deus barba feita parece de um fio
pro outro ela achou um barbeador em
algum lugar aí Tá todo mundo rodando
lado dizendo que aconteceu Tony Stark da
assustada cara com cinquenta por cento
das criaturas que foram admirado e fica
muito doido esse eu não falei eu disse
que esse negócio de universos meio da
Serra ninguém me escuta Capitão América
vai falar alguma coisa ele tá tudo
também p**** c****** e aí aquela maior
coisa aí eles fazendo a varredura no
Universo para saber onde é que tá o
thanos e nada de achar e não sei aonde o
que é que fazer é a filha do tênis assim
ah eu sei onde encontrar aí a Débora ela
tem falso
E aí ela publica vai fazer assim ó é o
Capitão América faz assim ó então vamos
pegar esse tipo ela da p*** zangado que
o Capitão América no xinga ele quase
fala assim vamos pegar esse bobão uma
balinha mas o número que tá usando a
capitã Marvel já dá uma volta no planeta
para saber que não tem ninguém só tempo
cara lá só vim embora numa Cabana anos
voltamos a casa do meu pai tá xingando a
blusa é de política fazendo um negocinho
tá na dele tá bem um poder na cara outro
no braço outro braço entre outro pescoço
agora já assistiu o meu show que tá na
Netflix que chamado outro aí eu tô não
deu tempo tá aí começa a falar mesmo já
peguei as pedras já destruir porque ela
quase não sei o que ela é um poder aqui
a tua falta a cabeça do thanos
em nada porque estou eu vou no chão se
vai ser um botijão de gás o homem virou
as costas ou esse aí meu amigo como está
perdido né não tem mais perto não tem
como voltar atrás Morreu todo mundo
odeia o foi tudo gosta para o Capitão
América numa roda de terapia contando a
vida tem Pois é rapaz me congelado tá
todo mundo triste morrendo de depressão
rato acidentalmente estava passando na
van do homem-formiga que tipo um negócio
do tempo também máquina do tempo que
tinha feito né É a vó do tempo aí eu
matar aciona sem querer desenvolver
formiga volta ó ela do rappi vocês
quando vê um rato é matar que o bichinho
rapaz é o reino animal se ajudando né
não rato ajudando a formiga porque tinha
passado um pouco tempo lá dentro mais
fora passou de cinco anos tá ligado E aí
ele voltou e não sabia de nada não sabe
o que é que acontecido lá de fora morreu
foi olhar a data das cores meu Deus do
céu minha nossa senhora Correu para casa
dele a filha dele já estava com vinte e
tantos anos o homem começa a chorar eu
pensei que era minha tristeza mas é de
felicidade que tinha assaltado a
adolescência da menina eu preciso
arrumar e passar por todo aquilo Car
o romanoff chorando lá porque enfim
cinco anos se passaram e nada aconteceu
cara todo mundo lá dentro chegam por
meio dizendo rapaz já tá na partículas
quânticas mundo quântico você sabe vamos
o mundo quântico galera é isso cara tem
que construir esse negócio que a gente
volta do tempo mexe com as pedras antes
do thanos para poder as coisas vão
acontecer vamos mudar vamos de Ferro
chegaram de Ferro já tem menino família
caso na interior já tirando leite de
vaca tá tá curtindo curtindo a vida dele
tranquilo tá perto ele de novo só doido
ver o Homem de Ferro feliz uma casa no
campo com a família dele os ovos chega
latejar com vontade de morar no campo
com a família eles vão atrás do Hulk que
tá um YouTube praticamente tá blogueiro
pessoas pedindo pra tirar foto com ele
ele ficou Grandão mesmo assumiu vai
ficar assim ou zangado de rasgar roupa
tô de rasgando roupa não vou ficar assim
mesmo é melhor para todo mundo vivendo
suas vidas sabe tá todo mundo já cinco
anos já passar eu Tony Stark
e lá para a cabeça dele pensando
pensando pensando meu deus o que é que
vai fazer como é que vamos ser quando
fez que não pai o seu estalo a
inteligência eo Tony Stark conversa com
a esposa dele Olha porque assim de
menino tudo bem né mas não precisa ir
até o poder lhe ver né tá crescendo lá e
que sei lá aí eu vou a Roma Nova o
homem-formiga e o Capitão América
constrói pela vamos lá né Para poder
voltar no tempo só que não dá certo que
os outros estão achando um lugar certo
eles tem que ir entendeu só que aí chega
um Tony Stark do que tava faltando é o
GPS da máquina dá para eu poder chegar
na máquina do tempo ir lá saber pode vai
eu achei ele já descobre que dá para ir
todo mundo mas faz umas roupas especiais
nós vamos lá no passado e aí a gente
pega as pernas e ainda tudo certo beleza
então que tem acontecer o Hulk vai lá na
casa do Tom chamar o toque que eu tô
depois que cortou a cabeça do thanos
virou entrou na dele e aí
o novo estranho isso isso eu vou falar
na casa o totó tá um Alambique morrendo
de depressão A para você ver como
depressão é o mal do século mesmo o
Capitão América tava na terapia O tornam
pode ouvir a palavra tamos que endoida
Alô rapaz e o thanos ele que eu fui eu
que matei ele não foi eu o que foi que
matou o cachorro que eu tô falando a
p*** todo mundo entendeu eu cheguei lá
tava conversando na cabeça da p*** o
cara não quer voltar ele tá todo mundo
para conseguir fazer essas coisas aí
começa a
é isso não não sei que papá cliente é
lógico que não dá para matar o thanos
bebê crueldade seja que bebê a pessoa
matar volta para antes de se mata o pai
dele nem você ia matar Só capa aí o
gavião se habilita Tá eu vou testar
então para ver se eu consigo ir aonde eu
quero e volto beleza aí ele volta para
casa dele ver lá as filhas dele fica
muito feliz e volta gente deu certo olha
eu trouxe aqui na minha mão alguma coisa
que estava lá no chão Vamos então aí vai
horror a né bula Capitão América o
homem-formiga gavião arqueiro romanoff
guaxinim Guardiões da Galáxia Homem de
Ferro o Hulk vai atrás daquela monge lá
do doutor estranho Sabe aquela merece
mesmo pensando que ia ser fácil pegar a
pedra da mulher a mulher dá só uma nele
aqui ó o homem fica em câmera lenta ui
pouco dei vou lá na casa do c******
torta vai para Terra dele né com
ansiedade né dando trabalho com o
guaxinim só um guaxinim para dar
conselho para o Thor só encontra a mãe
dele uma conversa muito poética Ser ou
não ser
Oi mãe eu deveria ser quem eu sou ou
será que eu sou aquilo que eu deveria
não ser e ela ser ou não ser não importa
o que ser o importante é ser você aí A
Malévola e aquele outro homem de ferro
né o James eles vão para o planeta do
thanos né E lá já conversa da m**** que
da venda na cabeça da Débora que ela é
de coisa de tecnológica futebol E aí a
outra medula aqui tá no tempo passado
começa a receber a mesmas informações na
cabeça dela aqui ó Rio tamos vendo tudo
olha aí [ __ ] a******** rolando e eu aqui
cara como é que pode aí na portaria aí
eles pega né mô deles volta lá que eu
não tem pena de por nenhuma mesmo passa
o negócio na cabeça pendura ela deixa
ela tá sofrendo lá e ficam vendo as
coisas pelo olho dela só que a outra né
bula Nossa eu digo a nossa o lado do bem
tá porque nós vamos bem foi de novo cara
esse negócio estranho aparecendo
piscando aqui no meio desse desse vídeo
aí então ficando brother a nossa né bula
ela ela acorda e percebe que eles viram
então eu devo todo já tá sabendo gente é
o meu e ela já conhece o pai dela falar
Não não vai me matar não vai mandar no
mundo de um agora vai acabar com os
outros 50 por cento nisso o Capitão
América já tá lá na casa do carai
pegando o terceratico está na mão dele
mesmo eu tando com ele mesmo você não
quer não viu o que você não me conhece
quem é você você gosta de gavião
arqueiro vamos lá da casa do c****** ele
lá veja bem nesse lugar Alguém tem que
se sacrificar só para um voltar com a
pedra tá
o começo falar um com o outro eu tenho
que ir no outro estão que eu te eu tenho
uma missão eu preciso desta lição alta
diz eu não tenho ninguém ninguém me ama
não vou fazer falta nesse mundo eu vou
pular outros não você não pode Só achei
muito linda se essa essa essa discussão
de tipo É o cúmulo outro não é um erro
puros não eu pulo Se fosse eu e um amigo
meu com certeza ia ser o contrário e as
é tipo assim vai então eu não vai não
não mas eu não posso cara todo mundo vai
sentir tua falta Ai meu Deus mas pode
deixar que eu conto o pessoal lá tá pode
vou lá pai um dois três não eu não posso
que eu estou devendo no mercado de lá de
casa eu chorei o homem que eu iria pagar
e eu sou uma pessoa de palavra então
pude meu amigo eu Sentirei saudade aí
voltaram no que voltaram cada um a ver
com Suas pedras já foram Botando o
negócio já já encaixaram já veio toda
vez que eu gozo Mateus de vou dar uma
coisa assim cara eu sou o Deus eu vou
que bota
é só poder que o universo ele vai
ficando assim acusada aí você começa a
escutar isso
e Os Passarinhos celular ligando as
esposas mantendo a filha do homem
formiga Liga para ele adolescente pai
você comprou isso para mim você não me
ama
e a todo mundo Felipe chega a turma do
plano o a nave do tamanho da casa do
carai já vai direto no quartel-general
do cinga desista preciso de boa agora é
o [ __ ] meu amigo vai começar pessoal
se arrastando pelo chão bancada segura o
Hulk tava gemendo para a nossa
homem-formiga se arrastando na terra
Gavião Arqueiro ele começa uma frente à
luz um monte de cachorro que é Satanás
para o cachorro que eu chamo é o bicho
que tem no ano assim vai fazendo assim a
espada no chão tomar uma cerveja O Homem
de Ferro 1
O que é escudo um papo borra isso Hulk
lá morrendo afogado Gavião Arqueiro
correndo dos achou rapaz tá isso tudo
aquele para luva do thanos da mão
correndo chega né Graças a Deus vou
passar para alguém passa para o papai
peguei um homem de ferro que ele nada
não sei como funciona um de ferro também
não acho que eu fosse um super-herói
Aparecida seria o homem marceneiro acho
que não gostei possui o roubou agora a
cadeira e o thanos é bom de peso viu
porque eles tavam para cima ele só dá
uma a
e vai lhe dar uma no torque o Thor Bate
umas pedras assim que quer ver eu acho
que o negócio é forte quando você passa
na pedra quebra a pedra meu amigo ele
pega esse Thor da Peppa para dar em três
pontos altos aí quando pensa que não
então América pega o martelo do Thor meu
meu amigo cinema vira a casa do c******
a galera eu falei p**** eu tinha um
amigo aí a briga bonita viu Capitão
América da humanos queixo do thanos
É pô
o mestre também para cima do Capitão
América assim com gosto de gás vai dando
naquele discurso até quebrar todinho
fica só objetivo e pega esse Capitão
América que dá tanto viu tô me fez
acabou agora fodeu ele levanta mesmo que
o homem vai à luta até o último segundo
Olha eu peço que desligue chega se não é
o Pantera Negra e começa a ver aí ver O
Guardião da Galáxia o exército todo de
uma canta a Peppa os guaxinins o doutor
estranho Olha a vó aí nós consagrado
deixar ele fica aquele clima de guerra
mesmo mas galera viva de lá eu tô vindo
de carro Capitão América diz assim ó tá
bem já tá culpada meu amigo por essa
galera aí não atendeu ao Big fone e
e vão correndo se encontra de primeiro
top já pega no 150 vamos formiga fica
grandão vai lá naquelas baleia voadora
eu acho que é uma baleia né Qual é a
passar um formiga pode fumar homem o
Pantera Negra em casa do Guardião da
Galáxia na planta assassino.de ferro vai
virando um tanque de guerra e chega
Mulher de Ferro 2 minutos junta-se o
cantaram a música Homem Aranha contra
Homem de Ferro cara e começa a conversar
todo está aqui você não sabe o que
aconteceu e o povo apoiando atrás eu não
tenho nem contra os caras e os acaba
apanhando cá
E aí O Senhor Das Estrelas vai encontrar
gamora Rua do Morro eu pensei que eu
tinha te perdido elas ontem tava na cara
eles começam a conversar e isso ocorra
no atrás chega aquele cara que a rua e
mata o monstro Gavião aquele da hoje
pode tá com a luva correndo eu vou para
onde leva para alguém tá vendo ele
falando não sei como eu tô vendo a pena
escutar naquela guerra mesmo tava no
meio da guerra de verdade lá na casa do
c****** p*** que pariu Homem de Ferro na
baixa da égua eles fala sem gritar sai
dando mortal a torto EA direita lá
e vai passar o plano os pés bati no
carro aí aparece a Feiticeira Escarlate
ela diz você me fez sofrer agora você
vai sentir todas as coisas que você me
fez sofrer diz doidinha não sei nem quem
tu é de irmão você vai saber agora
início povo apoiando atrás meu amigo
essa mulher pega esse tanto que espreme
que quase faz um sofá atrás de pau meu
amigo essa nós jogava poder como uma mãe
bate no filho para ele a feiticeira joga
um poder na espada do thanos que ela
quebra cara quatro ter noção ela quebrou
a espada que quebrou o escudo do Capitão
América e homem-aranha já tá morrendo eu
o Capitão América joga o Marcelo ele
pendurou no Marcelo saia Voando para
casa do c****** A Mulher de Ferro pega
ele joga com a mulher que tá voando com
cavalo que ele vai junto mulher o que eu
fico pensando porque que não joga
ah deixa para lá para salvar a
humanidade chegar ao gente ali viro ele
tá com pa dois dias Manda Fogo do Céu a
nave homem-aranha chorando e a gente
correndo menino chorando engraçado assim
um lugar que a todo queimado a fumaça
subindo pelo fogo e a galera vendo as
maravilhas tirando para o céu do nada
Vamos aumentando aumentando o meu Deus é
a capitã Marvel essa mulher atravessa
essa nave todinha de um lado a outro
chega a capitã Marvel do homem-aranha já
tá dentro do buraco assim ela pega
começa a chegar só as mulheres meu irmão
chegar a mulher do cavalos alados Mulher
de Ferro gamora capitã Marvel Luisa mell
do cavalo alado da baleia no meio com a
luva na mão na frente essa mulher sai
cortando no meio V
o padre todo na rua usam do c****** dela
que está tudo perdido em aí todo mundo
acima do plano Zé porre Capitão América
a galera chega Capitão Marvel tão aí ele
tá na Capitão Marvel como quem bate
assim no aparelho e ele vai para
instalar o dedo que ele botou a luva que
o bicho é desgraçado ele consegue pegar
mesmo c****** como é que pode buscar a
do c****** eu fico indignado tempo e
cara querendo decidiu destino do planeta
lei o meu Deus deixa a gente destruir
tudo só viu quem ganhou queimando atrás
já tava tomava segurando o dedo dele eu
digo vai quebra ele puxa uma pedra tão
nela ela vai-se embora meu amigo o
doutor estranho faz o sinal Olha é a
única possibilidade ou não
E aí é inevitável que não sei falar
inevitável em inglês e nada acontece
porque eu peguei as pedras seu
f************ E aí cara que ela promoção
mundo volta ao normal o homem de ferro
encosta e fala assim você já assistiu
especial de comédia do Whindersson Nunes
adulto no médico e morre taquipariu
bicho pelo homem de ferro assistir
Steven por mim mas pelo homem de ferro e
depois disso as coisas voltam que ele
tem várias coisas mais que acontece
depois mas eu não vou contar para botar
o filme inteiro aqui você assistir o
final do filme Quando você assistir Se
você tiver gostado clica em Gostei da
esqueça de se inscrever no canal também
porque vai ter muitos vídeos novos vai
entrar uma série que eu gravei pelo
mundo também aqui no canal você precisa
ver vai entrar outra série que eu tô
gravando aqui na minha casa mesmo que eu
inventei mesmo que eu tô fazendo eu
mesmo para você saber precisa ver então
clique e se inscrever tamo junto é nós
por favor não esquece de postar a sexta
adulto na Netflix no Twitter assim que
E aí agora por favor tamo junto é nóis
valeu Um beijão vir f